most of us fell in love with her as
Sloane on Entourage for all those years
and now part of the return of Super
Troopers Super Troopers 2 in theaters on
Friday April 20th or if I wasn't an NFL
employee I would say 20 but since I am
its I must say it's a week from this
fraud and fears Emmanuel shrieky and
that film good to see you
I mean this is this is one we just
showed up we just showed a clip of it
and just seeing you know we've got Jay
and Kevin coming in studio later on this
week I mean look you you you've been
part of so much from you know the Zohan
movie with Sandler and obviously
entourage of having fun on a set I
imagine this was something quite similar
it was it was a month in Boston we were
it was like summer camp it was the best
time to be there it was like August into
September okay so there were leaves
attorney yes it was so great and so many
fun dinners and you know listen there's
so many great comedians in this film
right and like I was telling you before
there was really witnessing like some
comedic genius and how they work how
they collaborate together to get the
joke it's it's good and that you know so
you their troupe is a Broken Lizard
comedy team and it's written and
starring the Broken Lizard comedy team
so cool out of those that were also in
this film that you got to be on the set
with was were you there when Rob Lowe
was there too or okay my character
actually works with Rob Lowe's character
so I was there I was there for the
entire time so the only one that I
didn't get to spend any real quality
time with was Lynda Carter Wonder Woman
I mean did you know she's going to be at
the New York premiere okay so I'm gonna
make sure to get a royalty
I mean Lynda Carter is royalty did she
just get a star on the I think she did I
don't know but she deserves it she
deserves it certainly again the 12 year
old version of me would say she deserves
you know from from way back in the day
so now he last time we spoke we talked
about you know you throw out a first
pitch at a Dodgers game and things of
that nature
do you have
recently come off another moment where
you you did something physical at a
sporting event yes what's this about
you're hanging out are few and far
between but there's one was for the
Lupus Foundation Michael B Jordan had
done this big charity day and I had to
do a shot and if I got it in we would
make $15,000 and I got it in it's on my
Instagram so how how far we talking
about 10 feet 15 three-point shot it was
a side one it was like from the side it
was for sure like maybe 10 feet right it
was proper okay Michael B gave me like a
big high five it was a nice moment that
works like that who else was who else
was hanging out with you right um for
the Lupus Foundation I should there was
a bunch of people you know what nobody
that I was super familiar with but a lot
of Mike's friends it was good the cast
have Creed pretty much there I mean look
I mean Michael B Jordan he's crushing it
right now there's no question about that
yeah alright so now we were talking
before about you know with Russell Crowe
selling anything off what what what what
what stuff from your career do you have
in your garage or something like that or
just hanging out something from your do
you know what I actually had to let go a
long story short there is this book it's
called the life-changing magic of
tidying up by Marie Kondo and she makes
you get rid of clutter I don't do that
it's but the emotional there's a part
for like emotional things yes you take
pictures of Devon's or whatever for me I
was so gung-ho of getting rid of stuff I
had like 50 hoodies like how many
entourage hoodies there's one personally
I had a lot well did each hoodie have a
significance from seeing that you were
in season
okay a season two hoodie oh I see what
you're saying I mean which by the way is
a little cheesy to go out rocking my
your entourage
- rug did you know I don't know I just
went on vacation and I rocked a Rich
Eisen show cap is that was that wrong it
was international though he's in it what
do you what do you always branding rich
always branding you know I'm trying I
know what you're saying I have a bag
that I travel with to the airport and
it's like small and it just says you
know entourage season eight and I'm like
I'm okay with that it's good bag all
right so you have that Syrian out you're
not getting rid of all that stuff yeah
okay and then Dell Tufo we we had this
before too we discussed this I don't
know if you heard in the green room my
car audio executive as he likes to be
called yes it's the question because for
some reason we're giving him a platform
to answer questions and people have
asking him for advice somebody asked you
about what your what a great idea for a
first date is yes okay okay and you want
to tell the manual what your idea great
for a first date is helicopter ride to
Catalina dinner and back yes
really for a first date somebody that
you've you've just met oh yeah really
you an impression
you wouldn't be totally freaked out if
somebody no I would be like wow this is
your first day I can't wait to see what
the second date is that would be a
flight to San Francisco actually did do
the San Francisco thing oh I did do that
right after I got divorced now it just
gets creepier that's not a prop to me
that seems pretty damn aggressive so you
want to know why cuz I feel like these
days hmm
your first date you've already done so
much research on each other like it's
not there's no blind dates anymore
that you have the internet and you have
the whatever all these Twitter Google so
you really have an idea of like who this
person is
okay so if you find out that this person
is
somebody who works a sound board but
refers to himself as an audio executive
okay where's cargo shorts all the time
and and and on top of all of it has his
own you stream on Friday night where he
sits in his apartment condo and DJs for
all those who are watching live via
Ustream that person offers you a
helicopter flight to Catalina that's
still you're still in I mean listen if
that person yes is into all of those
things
yeah you're so sweet because when you
walked on the set Chris is like say oh
I'm friends with Aaron and Michael I
thought you were just being nice yeah
yeah yeah hundred percent homey yeah so
this is legit you actually know the
people that dropped and you you think
Mike del two foes idea for a first date
is because I thought that's really
aggressive I mean listen if like there
is some woman that would 100% appreciate
that and be like wow that was epic Wow
for everybody no definitely not
I always back in my dating days always
dated somebody after the first date he
was always within two to three weeks of
her birthday and then I was always put
in a position of like okay I I kind of
like her but if I now try and make it so
special you know but that's why I'm
saying a helicopter flight I'm just
trying to get you to say that he doesn't
know a damn thing about it you know that
run a new bike yeah not that much it's
about 425 give or take what would be no
no
no no for you on a first date then what
would that be in an out burger you know
what you know what you want to know what
likes your lame leg up the first date
was like yeah so let's go get dinner and
go see a movie
mm-hmm IV like no really a movie yeah
cuz there's no conversation conversation
it's so lame
don't get to know each other you can do
that like when you've been dating for
six months what if the movie Super
Troopers 220th
a week from this Friday well done well
done otherwise known as 4/20 by some
people I don't understand I don't get
what's being put down at the shrieky on
Twitter I follow you there as well as on
Instagram as well come back anytime you
want thank you absolutely flabbergasting
the next ask Mike doe - faux session
session when's that next week once a
week will do less is more for the guy
who wants to fly to Catalina with
somebody they just met oh my god believe
it super troopers doing theaters near
you Friday 4:20 good to see you
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience